[LOGO MUSIC]
MATHIEU CHARTIER:
Hello everyone.
Thank you all for coming,
and let's get started.
So I'm Mathieu, and
today, my colleagues and I
will be talking about how
we are making the Android
Runtime, also known as ART,
faster in Android Q. We will
also be showing you both some
internal knowledge about ART
as well as some best
practices, such as using
the reportfully drawn API
as well as when to use
object pooling.
And now a recap
about how ART works--
so ART is the software layer in
between the Android operating
system and the applications.
It provides an
execution environment
for running both Kotlin
and Java language
applications on Android.
To do this, ART does two things.
It processes dex files, the
internal format of Android
applications, through a
hybrid model consisting
of interpretation, just
in time compilation,
and profile-based ahead
of time compilation.
ART also manages memory by
having automatic reclamation
through a concurrent compacting
garbage collector that we
introduced in Android Oreo.
So an update on
profiles in the cloud--
so ART has had profiles
that contain information
about application usage
on Android since Nugget.
And, until recently,
these profiles
are only local to the device.
These profiles are collected
by the just in time compiler
and are saved to device storage
during application execution
and later are used to
optimize the application.
Since these were only
locally stored on the device
until recently, this
meant that applications
had to run a while,
have their profile
saved, and then we had to
optimize the application when
the phone was charging
or when the device
was charging in the background.
To address this, we introduced
a new service called Profiles
in the Cloud, which was
announced last year at Google
I/O. And today, we're going
to be providing some more
updates about how that's going.
So, before we dive into
profiles in the cloud,
let's take a closer look at
what's inside of a profile.
Profiles contain
detailed information
about an application usage,
including what methods are run
and what classes are
loaded during both startup
and during a steady state
of the application usage.
This enables ART to
compile the methods that
are the most important
to machine code
as well as optimize the
application for startup
by prioritizing code
that is rendering
startup for performance.
Profiles in the cloud enable
downloading the profile
alongside the application
during installation
and then optimizing
the application
during installation.
This means that the users
get the performance directly
after installation
and no longer have
to wait for the application
to get optimized
when the device is
charging in the background.
So here we have
observed speed ups
of around 15% faster
application startup directly
after installation.
So now let's dive into how
the whole profile in the cloud
process works.
So the main idea here is
that applications usually
have commonly shared code paths
between a multitude of users
and devices.
So this means that most users
are going to have generally
the same use case for a
startup and the application
usage in general.
So what we want to do
with profiles in the cloud
is have the initial users
bootstrap performance
for the rest of the users.
And this often takes advantage
or benefits from the fact
that developers roll out
applications incrementally
with alpha beta channels.
So once an application
is installed,
the profiles are
uploaded to Play,
and they're aggregated into
what we call a common core
profile for the application.
And in future installs,
this common core profile
is downloaded alongside
the application
and used to optimize
during installation.
This improves both the steady
state performance as well as
the startup.
I'd like to note
that Android P also
has API support that non-Play
devices can leverage.
As for numbers, as
you can see here,
YouTube has a large
startup improvement
around 18% from
profiles in the cloud,
and other applications also
have substantial improvement.
This is field data of Google
applications collected
from Pixel devices.
And one of the best
parts of all this
is that developers and users
get the benefits for free.
Developers don't have to
write a single line of code
to enable the profiles
for their applications,
and users will have to take
any action to get the benefits.
And right now, around
80% of installations
on devices with
Google Play services
use profiles in the cloud.
Another interesting
observation is
that the profiles
in the cloud seem
to show that only around
20% of application code
is commonly used.
This could indicate that
there are opportunities
to reduce code size by removing
unused code in applications.
And now let's go to app startup.
We have done some
improvements in Q,
and I'll be going
over some of those.
In Android Q, we have done
three major new improvements.
We've improved the application
images originally introduced
in Android Nugget to provide
a larger startup improvement.
We have added pre-forking
of application processes
to accelerate process
creation on Android.
And we have added
a new generation
of garbage collector.
So starting with
application images,
recall that
application images, as
if you see in other
years' I/O talks,
are actually
serialized snapshots
containing the classes that
are the most commonly used
during startup of
an application.
So this optimizes
the performance
by shifting the work of loading
those classes from happening
during startup to
happening ahead of time
in the ART ahead
of time compiler.
So the application
image is generated
by the compiler taking
both the application, APK,
and the profile as inputs
and then using the profile
to know specifically
what classes are loaded
during startup and including
only these in the application
images.
This is done during
installation if there
is a profile from
the cloud present.
Otherwise, it's normally
done in the background
when a device is charging.
So how have we improved
our application images
in Android Q?
Well, we recently observed
that string interning caused
specifically by using string
literals in applications
startup was taking a
large amount of time.
So we added an optimization
to include the string literals
that are commonly used during
startup for the application
inside of the application image.
This is accomplished by
leveraging the profile
to know specifically
what methods
are executed during startup.
So, as you can see
here, there is around
a 2.5% improvement
on some applications,
and this is a selection of
first party applications running
on a Pixel to Excel.
And now let me hand
it off to Chris
for pre-forking
application processes.
CHRIS WALLES:
Thank you, Mathieu.
Hello, everyone.
My name is Chris, and I
am here to talk about some
of the changes we have made
to the Zygote in Android Q
to help improve application
startup performance.
For those of you
unfamiliar with the Zygote,
this is the process in
Android that all applications
are spawned from.
This design allows us to
take several steps that
are common to all
Android applications
and perform them before the
applications are launched.
Unfortunately, in previous
versions of Android,
there were still several
application agnostic steps
that had to be performed after
the application was launched.
These include such things
as process spawning,
thread creation driver
loading, and resource cleanup.
In Android Q, we're introducing
the unspecialized app process
pool.
Unspecialized app
processes are created
and perform these application
agnostic steps off
the critical path of
application startup.
This produces an
average speed-up
of approximately 5 milliseconds
for most applications
on a Pixel Two device.
But more importantly,
it forms a foundation
for further improvements
to application startup.
So now, let's take
a look at some
of the changes we've made to
the early stages of app startup
to make it faster.
On the left, we can see
the launching process
from previous
versions of Android.
It involves three communicating
processes, one of which
must be created during this
critical launch window.
It also involves inter-process
communication, or IPC,
and this requires the Zygote
to wake up, block, unblock,
and send a message
to the system server.
All of these steps
take resources
away from the operating
system and the application
that the user is
trying to launch.
On the right, we can see the
new, much-simpler app launch
process in Android Q. The Zygote
has been completely removed
from this critical path.
Also, the new process that
will become the application
already exists in the system and
has performed these application
agnostic steps already.
By removing the Zygote,
we also eliminate
an entire inter-process
communication round.
And this means that the new
application can talk directly
to the system server and not
wake up the Zygote and consume
system resources.
In a couple slides, I'm
going to be talk about some
of the metric and investigation
work we've done in Android Q
to help improve applications
startup performance.
But I wanted to briefly
mention the metric that
is directly impacted
by these changes, which
is time to first slice.
Time to first slice is
a measure of how quickly
we can begin running
application-specific code.
And, as we can
see in this graph,
there is a fairly uniform
improvement, again,
of approximately five
milliseconds to the time
to first slice metric
for these seven apps
on a Pixel Two device.
However, this is
just the beginning
for the speed-ups
and improvements
we can see from using
unspecialized app processes.
Follow up work that is
currently in testing
shows an additional
speed-up on the order
of tens of milliseconds.
The best news for
users and developers
alike is that all applications
will see these improvements
without requiring any changes
to their application or they way
that they use their device.
So now I'm going to talk briefly
about the measurement work
that we've been doing in Android
Q. When performance tuning
software as complicated
as an operating system,
it's very important to get
a deep understanding of what
is happening, when
it's happening,
and how long it is taking.
To this end, we've
spent a lot of time
looking at traces in log files
over the last couple months.
We've also developed
several new tools
for extracting actionable
and useful insights
from this large corpus of data.
One of these tools is
publicly available to you,
and that's the startup
analyzer script.
This script will extract
detailed information
about startup events
from trace files,
including startup duration,
scheduling status,
and binder transactions.
One of the most
important questions
that this work made us
ask ourself is, when
does application startup end?
Well, there are many
criteria that we
can use that might signal
when startup is finished,
including when the first frame
of the user interface is drawn.
And this is certainly
a useful definition.
It's one we can use to
optimize performance.
But it doesn't tell us when the
user perceives the application
to be usable, which
is what we consider
to be the gold standard for
application startup endpoint.
Unfortunately, we don't have
a way to automatically detect
when this happens.
We do, however, have an
API call that developers
can use to tell us when
you think it happens.
This makes it easier for us
to identify the application
startup process
for individual apps
and make sure that we
optimize the things that
are important to your app.
So if you would like
to help us speed up
the performance of
your application,
I highly recommend that you
use this reportfully drawn API
call.
So thank you for your time.
And at this point, I'm going to
hand the stage over to Roland
for a discussion of the
garbage collection work
that we've done in Q.
ROLAND LEVILLAIN:
Thank you, Chris.
Hi, everyone.
My name is Roland, and
I'm going to present
the improvements we've
made in ART's Garbage
Collector for Android Q.
In Android Q, we've improved
ART's concurrent copying
Garbage Collector in two ways--
first, by adding support
for generational garbage
collection, which makes
GC cheaper overall--
and second, by using a two
phase collection strategy which
makes garbage collection more
precise and able to reclaim
more objects.
During the development
of Android Q,
we've also re-evaluated
the benefits
of object pooling versus
standard allocation in ART.
In the last section
of this talk,
we'll share with you our
findings and new recommendation
regarding object pooling.
But for now, let's have a
look at garbage collection,
generational garbage collection.
In Android 8 Oreo, we introduced
a concurrent copying garbage
collector, or CC
collector, in ART.
This year, we are adding support
for generational collection
to this collector.
In Android Q, the CC
collector alternates
full heap collections and
young generation collections.
These young generation
collections only
process a fraction of the heap.
They are cheaper and
almost as effective
as full heap collections.
Before we look at
generational collection,
let's have a quick look at how
the concurrent copying garbage
collector works.
The garbage collector in ART
is a concurrent copying one.
It is concurrent because it
runs at the same time on an app
thread, and it does not require
a long stop the world pause.
This work, thanks
to a cooperation
between the GC and
the app's code,
all accesses to
object references
are instrumented in
the runtime with what
we call read barriers.
And they ensure that the app
does not see a stale object.
The GC is also
said to be copying
because it moves live objects in
memory by making a copy of them
and reclaiming the space that
held the original objects,
including the data objects.
This copying strategy means that
the GC is compacting the heap
and preventing fragmentation.
Let's see how this works.
Copying collector
traditionally splits
the manage heap in two spaces--
a from space, which contains
the object currently allocated
and used, and a two space, to
which live object are moved
during garbage collection.
During a GC cycle, the
collector traces the heap.
It follows root references to
manage objects, for instance,
from its third stack and
marks all objects reachable
from these roots to compute
the set of live objects.
The eventual objects in dark
red in this illustration
are the ones which are not
visited by the collector.
Reachable objects are
copied to the to-space
as they are being
marked by the GC.
And likewise, all other
reachable objects living
in the from-space are
copied to the to-space.
They're being marked,
thus compacting the heap.
At the end of the
collection, the objects
that haven't been
moved are the dead ones
because they're not reachable.
And the GC can then reclaim the
memory used by the from-space.
Finally, the from-space and
the to-space are swapped,
and new locations happen
in the new from-space.
So that's heap
compaction in a nutshell.
Let's see how this works in ART.
So for practical
reasons, ART CC collector
does not use two semi-spaces
but a region space composed
of 256 kilobytes regions.
As an app's memory
needs grow over time,
new regions are allocated to
create space for new objects.
As in the previous
example, we're
highlighting unreachable
objects in dark red color.
At the beginning of a GC
cycle, the garbage collector
makes a decision for
each region in use.
The first option is to
evacuate a region, which
means moving all live
objects out of it
and reclaim the memory
backing the region
at the end of the cycle.
This makes sense if there's a
good proportion of dead objects
in this region
because evacuating
it means it will
help compact the heap
and free some physical memory.
But if most of the allocated
objects in these regions
are actually alive, there
would be little benefits
to evacuate it and maybe some
costs because of the object
copies.
In that case, the
GC might decide
to keep the region
as is, and we call
that an unevacuated region in
dark green in this diagram.
Until Android Q, the decision
to evacuate a region or not
was based on information
from a previous GC
cycle, which is not optimal.
Later in this talk,
my colleague Lokesh
will talk more about this.
Tracing and marking
work similarly
to the previous example.
But instead of copying
evacuated object
to a fixed to-space
area, they're
copied to a freshly allocated
region called an evacuation
region.
If this region speeds up
during garbage collection,
another region is
allocated and so on
until the whole heap
has been traced.
At the end of the GC
cycle, the to-space
is in union of
all the evacuation
regions and the region that had
been allocated for new object
locations.
Evacuated regions
eventually are reclaimed,
and their memory pages are
returned to the system.
Now that we've seen how ART's
concurrent collector works,
let's have a look at this
generational version.
Even if the CC collector does
not evacuate all regions,
it has to trace all the objects.
This is known as a
full heap collection.
But consider this.
If the GC were to
process only recently
allocated objects, if will in
general collect most of them
and for a fraction of the cost
of a full heap collection.
This is what we call the
generational hypothesis.
In most cases, young
objects are much more
likely to die than old objects.
ART's generational CC collector
introducing the concept
of young generation collection--
only tracing recently
allocated regions.
These are called
minor collections
as opposed to full
heap collections with
are called major collections.
This is GC heuristics,
which tries
to use minor collection first,
and it runs major collections
if needed.
In a young generation
collection,
we handle newly allocated
regions specially.
These regions are the ones
which have been allocated
in the previous GC
cycle, and the objects
are much more likely
to be unreachable.
Therefore, these regions are
the only one thereby created
during a minor collection.
And they are also
the only regions
which are being traced
during a minor collection.
Old generation
objects have survived
at least one
collection, and they are
more likely to be still alive.
So they are not traced
during a minor collection.
Overall, this results in
a much faster GC cycle.
By tracing young generation
regions from the roots and--
oh, sorry.
In order to only trace objects
in the young generation,
we need to determine
their reachability.
To do so, we need
to track references
from the roots to
the young object
as we did in the full
heap collections,
but we also need to trace
references from old object
to young objects because the
old objects do not trace.
We track old to young object
references using a remember set
mechanism which keeps
tracks of references,
objects whose fields have been
modified since the last GC
cycle.
Minor recollection-- sorry.
Yeah, by tracing the
young generations
from the roots
and remember sets,
we can identify
live young objects
and copy them out of the
region without the need
to trace the whole heap.
And this is the main benefit
of minor collections.
Minor collections do not
possess all generation object
that could have been reclaimed
in a full collection.
We call that floating garbage.
They will eventually
be collected
during the next full
heap collection.
Let's now see the impact
of generational CC
on ART's performance.
To assess the impact of
generational CC collection
on ART, we've measured
the average time
spent in the garbage
collector thread
on some GC intensive benchmarks.
We used the H2 benchmark
from the [INAUDIBLE] suite,
which is an in memory
database benchmark,
as well as our
internal guided sheets
benchmark because both are
good examples of allocation
and garbage
collection workloads.
On average, the generational CC
collector is 38% faster on H2
and 33% faster on
sheets when compared
with the non-generational
garbage collector
that we shipped in Android P.
This is a direct result
of a younger generation
collection being cheaper
in term of CPU time.
So to put it in a nutshell,
using short-live objects
is now cheaper.
And also as a consequence
of these improvements,
we expect that because
we are spending less time
in the garbage collector, this
will benefit the device battery
life.
Improvements in
garbage collection
often highlight trade offs
between CPU and RAM usage.
Generational garbage collector
may keep some objects
a bit longer in order to speed
up the overall GC execution.
To talk more about how we can
improve these trade and heap
compaction, I'm handing
it over to Lokesh.
LOKESH GIDRA: Thank you, Roland.
Hi, everyone.
I hope you still have
some stamina left
for more technical stuff.
So let's start off with
talking a little bit more
about how heap
compaction works in CC.
So as you can imagine,
the more live objects
there are in a
compacting region,
the lesser memory
you would reclaim
if you were to compact it.
And so it makes
more sense to only--
for a higher rate of
investment, to only
compact those regions which have
considerable garbage in them.
And that's exactly what
concurrent copying collector
does.
We maintain a per
region liveness
stat, which indicates
how much lack of data
is there in a particular
region and, based on that,
decide which regions are worth
evacuating and which are not.
Another interesting fact
about the CC algorithm
is that, during a
GC cycle, it only
goes through all the
reachable objects only once.
While this is a very useful
fact about any GC algorithm
because it shows how
efficient that algorithm is,
let's see how it affects
the heap compaction
decisions that we make.
So this is a
hypothetical timeline
of some app's execution.
And as you can imagine, during
the execution, periodically,
we need to perform
GC cycles in order
to reclaim memory which is
consumed by unreachable objects
so that future object
allocations can be solved.
And since CC, until Android
P, was not relational, so all
these GC work on all
the reachable objects.
And therefore, I am calling
them full heap GC cycles.
So when me start off
with the first GC cycle,
by the time we visit all
the reachable objects,
we know precisely
which region has
how many live bytes in them.
And therefore, we can
gather the liveness stats
that I talked about
in the previous slide.
As the time goes by, due to
the execution of application
threads, the heap mutation would
result in more objects becoming
unreachable.
However, by the time the next
GC cycle is executed where
you would actually use the
stats that you gathered
in the previous GC cycle,
those liveness stats no longer
show you the liveness
at that point in time.
This leads to what Roland
earlier described--
floating garbage, which is
the unreachable objects that
the garbage collector
knows about,
but it cannot collect them.
And of course, as in
the previous GC cycle,
by the end of this
GC cycle also,
since we have gone through
all the life objects,
we gathered the liveness
stats which then
are used in the next GC cycle.
And this goes and on.
This is how decision
making works in Android P.
Now let's see how introducing
generations into this
affects the decision making
for region selection.
As Roland described earlier,
the benefits of generational GC
is that we can reduce the
number of full heap GC cycles
by replacing them with more
frequent young collections,
which are much more
lightweighted, as they only
work on young objects,
young reachable objects.
And, therefore,
what this leads to
is that you would have
less full heap GC cycles
but also that the time lag
between two full heap GC cycles
would increase.
And so, given that, when we
start execution, the first GC
cycle being full
heap GC cycle, we
compute the liveness as I
described in the previous case.
However, every time when we
perform young collection,
we cannot update these stats
because we only go through
young objects.
And, since we don't go through
all the reachable objects,
It's not possible to
update the liveness stats.
And, by the time we reach the
next full heap GC cycle where
we actually use
the liveness stats,
they become much
more stale than what
it would have happened in
case of Android P or earlier.
And therefore, it leads
to a larger amount
of floating garbage.
And this goes on and on.
Given the limited availability
of memory on mobile devices,
it makes sense to ensure
that this floating
garbage is minimal.
And the cause of
that we identified
is clear-- that the
outdated liveness
stats is what is hurting us.
So we fixed the issue by
improving the heap compaction
by replacing the full heap GC
cycle with another algorithm
which is two-phased, where
the first phase would
trace all the live
reachable objects
and compute the liveness stats.
And then the second phase, based
on these up-to-date liveness
stats, figures out
revision, which
regions deserve to be compacted,
and then performs compaction.
This way, we reap both the
benefits of generational GC
by ensuring that young
collection remains
as it is as well as we fix the
problem of outdated liveness
stats.
Let's see, using
the same example
that Roland was earlier using,
how this new algorithm works.
So let's assume that our
evacuation criteria get
a criteria for any
reason is that if it
has less than three
live objects in it,
then it deserves
to be compacted.
So, in this example,
as you can see,
that all the four
regions which are in use,
they have less than three
live objects in them.
So, by the time we finish
the first phase, which
goes through all the
reachable objects,
we have determined that all the
four regions have the liveness
stats less than three objects.
And therefore, they
deserve to be evacuated.
And, by the time we finish
our full heap GC cycle,
we managed to move all of
them into a single region,
thereby reclaiming all the four
previously used regions back.
Coming to what should it lead
to in terms of improvement,
the direct improvement
of this change
is that after every
full heap GC cycle,
we should be collecting
more free freed bytes back
from the garbage collector.
And, to measure that,
we use the same set
of applications and benchmark
data Roland earlier described.
And, as you can
see that, for H2,
the average freed bytes
improved by more than 178%
whereas for sheets,
it improved by 68%.
That's pretty good.
In terms of impact of both the
GC improvements that Roland
and I talked about on
the overall improvement
on the benchmark score, we
again ran some benchmarks.
And we observed that,
for H2, the score
improved by more than 15%
for both ARM and ARM64
whereas for sheets, it
improved by more than 5%.
All right, enough bragging
about improvement in Q.
Let me touch a different topic.
Let's talk about
object allocation
and object pooling
before I conclude.
I'm sure many of you must
have experienced this.
You start writing an app with
standard object allocation,
you know-- simple way
using new operator.
But as it grows
more and more, you
start either observing that
there's just too much GC
activity going on or you
are spending too much time
allocating new objects.
Or maybe just somebody said that
GC is inefficient in general,
and we should avoid it.
And then an idea
comes to your mind.
What if I can cheat
the garbage collector?
What if, instead of
giving those objects
once I'm done using them
giving them back to the garbage
collector, I could just
keep them around in pools
and use them again and again?
Isn't it obvious
that this should
lead to less garbage and
therefore less GC activity
and also that we would be
avoiding the allocation cost?
Given that in the
last few years,
Android's garbage collector
has made several improvements,
we thought it's nice time
to actually relook into it
and see if it really makes
sense to pool objects or not.
So we developed a
micro-benchmark,
the idea of basically
gathering two sets of metrics.
One is, what is the
allocation overhead
for standard allocation versus
acquiring from an object pool?
And second is that
what is the overall CPU
overhead of completing
the micro-benchmark?
So, starting it on
allocation overhead,
as you can see in this
chart that as you increase
the number of fields of the
object that you are pooling,
the overhead of
pooling an object
versus standard allocation
is almost the same.
So, from allocation
overheads point of view,
it actually does not make much
sense to pool the objects.
Going to the CPU
overhead, this chart
shows the best case for pooling.
And, obviously, as
expected, the best case
was that basically, there is
no garbage collection activity
at all.
And therefore, the
total CPU overhead
of completing the benchmark
in case of pooling
was lesser than
standard allocation.
However, there's a catch.
The catch is that the best
case loses its practicality
as soon as you go
beyond a test program
and start having more and
more complicated code.
Why?
Because you can't be
pooling every type of
object in your app.
You just can't do that.
And, therefore, we
thought we'll made
the benchmark more reasonable.
And so we added constant
short-lived allocations
in between each iteration
to see how it affects it.
And as you can see that
the gap between pooling
versus standard
allocation has reduced.
We went one step
further, and we made
that short-lived
allocation proportional
to the size of the object
that you're pooling.
And now as you can see,
after a certain size,
the overhead of pooling is
more than standard allocation.
And the main reason behind this
is that even though by pooling,
you are reducing the number of
GC cycles that gets invoked,
but you are
increasing the memory
footprint of your program.
You have more objects each
time to collect or to process.
And of course, in addition,
to higher footprint,
there are many other
disadvantages too,
like you bring back
all the nightmares
of double free and
memory leaks back.
And also, given the narrow gap
between standard allocation
and pooling, it is very critical
that your implementation
of the pool itself is efficient.
Otherwise, pooling
would very quickly
become more
inefficient as compared
to standard allocation.
So our recommendation
is that please
don't use it unless you are
really sure of the benefits.
And the best way to be sure
of benefits is to measure.
If measure when you
want to introduce
a new poll to your program, see
if it benefits you, and then
only use it.
However, I still
would say that there
are some corner cases where
it could be useful, right?
So for instance, if your
app has a requirement where
very large objects
need to be used,
then it may make
sense to pool them.
Or if there are thread
local objects which
get allocated and
then drop on the floor
at a very high
frequency, then also
it may make sense to pool them.
But the key point
here is please measure
before deciding to use them.
OK, so, to recap, we talked
about how we improved the app
startup time by
using cloud profiles,
by improving the app images, and
by introducing the app process
pools.
On the GC's front, we already
have faster object allocation
since Android Oreo.
And, starting with
Q, we have introduced
the concept of generational
garbage collection
and, also, we improved the heap
compaction using the two phase
algorithm that I talked about.
And since it is our
endeavor to always keep
improving the ART's
performance, we
will continue to
work on these areas.
And you can expect to have
more improvements in the future
to follow.
With that, thanks a lot for
attending the presentation.
I hope it was useful.